[Music]
chris is in san jose hey chris what's up
hello how are you all doing thank you
for taking my call better than we
deserve you're welcome how can we help
yes we're in kind of a unique situation
uh we just recently moved to san jose
from oklahoma and we sold our home there
and we want to follow the baby steps and
listening the show for a little bit um
but we also want to be able to buy a
house someday we have four children
and
we're not sure if we should follow the
baby steps even though i normally know
you would recommend doing that
we have about three to six months
of
reserves but my job is not necessarily
very secure because i'm a pastor
and because it's so expensive here would
put us in a really bad spot if we were
to
use the money that we have in savings to
pay off our two vehicles which we could
pay them both off right now but it would
leave us with no savings
we just bought a new van because we have
a fourth child
so
we're not sure how to proceed we have no
retirement to speak of except for my
wife's retirement who's about to be a
stay-at-home mom as well
based on the situation that we have four
children she has about twelve thousand
in her retirement account which what's
your uh what's your income
um make seventy five thousand per year
uh but that's before tax i'm considered
um
self-employed but then i also get
another
2200 per month from a va disability why
is it why is it not stable
well just why did you move your family
from oklahoma city to california to a
not stable situation
i found out more about the finances
after i got here um
i was a full-time student before that
going through college or seminary this
is my first job as a pastor i
didn't understand that we didn't have as
much money in terms of the church
and what we're bringing in and this is
the first time they've ever had two
pastors on staff
they already had one on staff um
so i was not completely aware
of how it could be we're getting by it's
been a year now and everything's good
this far it's just
i suppose it's unstable in the sense
that
if something went south at all god
forbid something like covet happen again
or whatever it
you know i might be the first one that
gets let go as is my fear there so
what do you owe in your cars
we owe a little less than 11 000 on one
vehicle and then the one we just
purchased is we owe 32 000 we just
bought that one you can't afford that
car pastor
okay
you way overbought on car
that's
i look for about a year bullcrap the
inventory oh crap not buying it
you make 75 000 a year you bought you
got a fourth kid and your mother your
mother your wife told you to go buy a
van and you did but you weigh over
purchase you put your family in jeopardy
with that with that purchase that
purchase was very unwise and that's me
being kind
okay you need to sell it
and you need to get a van that'll haul
your kids
for about 10 000 bucks
and then let's just pay all of that off
and then all of a sudden your life is
stable again the destabilizing factor
here is this van that's what's caused
everything to go on tilt
you didn't have this van situation
you'll be able to pay off the other one
you'll pay off a cheaper van and still
have money left over and you wouldn't be
freaking out
but the fact that you want to pay off
something that you can't afford
forty thousand dollars total thirty and
eleven
and then leaves you with no money and
when the church is also financially
unstable that's a problem now i don't
know how you're going to go home and
sell that
[Laughter]
yeah it depends on how new it is and
you've got so much tied up in things
that are going down in value no i mean i
don't know how you're going to sell that
to mama oh yeah i agree she's not going
to be happy but they'll be happy with it
yeah who did what yeah yeah well you
guys you guys did an impulse purchase
based on the emotion of a new baby and
moving to a new city that you really
cannot afford
you really really
stepped in it
and um you know you got if if i woke up
in your shoes that's exactly what i
would do and then i would pay then i
would pay off
i pay cash for whatever you buy get this
will probably sell for pretty close to
what you paid for it
since you just got it but
you simply bought something you can't
afford when you have
more than half of your annual income
tied up and things that go down in value
it's very difficult to prosper
very difficult and cars and anything
with wheels and motors goes down in
value period
uh and so this is just a it's
you know
you guys did a lot of you know you
graduated you from seminary you moved
you took a new job you're in california
you got a new baby there's a lot going
on so i'll cut you some slack but uh but
you got to go back and undo this
decision yeah and i would just you know
challenge you pastor that you know this
with your training you're in ministry
you're going to have to go home and talk
to your wife about this and this is
going to have to be vision casting not
demands you're going to have to she's
got a safety gland and she's got that
desire glenn and she wanted that van and
you you got the new baby and she really
loves that van she's probably never had
a van that nice that's a tough battle to
fight but the way you win that is i
would literally take that car payment
and i if i were gonna do this with stacy
i would write that figure big on a piece
of paper this is what we're paying per
month and then i would just do some
simple math times 12 times 24 times 36
so she can see if we sell this van and
we don't have this car payment anymore
look how much more money we actually
have and really speak to her safety
gland i think that's the best way to do
this
i really do proverbs 22 7 says the
borrower is slave to the lender and sir
you are feeling that yeah
you're feeling trapped and you know you
are
and that's what did this and so um sorry
but that's exactly what i would do if i
woke up in your shoes and if you don't
do this you have left your family
vulnerable
not the church that doesn't that is that
is in question
not the move
not you being
uh called to the ministry none of those
things left your family vulnerable a
stinking van did
so let's just call stuff what it is
so
that that's what that's what the danger
it's a danger point is what it is
and it without the pressure of that
particular thing
this whole situation changes pretty
dramatically